Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn his time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
Dan.
Ah,
uh,
yes.
Checking out here.
Just checking in on Ya dumb officially out of ways to say that and there's a
hole in this little hole in the wall in this fucking room.
These guys fix the pipes because there was galvanized piping in here and uh,
I never got this whole fixed.
Just fucking realize that that's how fucked up my house is.
You know what I realized?
I talk about my house so much that there's somebody sitting there going like,
eventually he's going to run out of money probably right when the house is 98%
fixed and I'm going to swoop in and buy it.
And he's gone in and redone everything,
redid everything I'm speaking of which I got the epoxy floor put in on my gym.
I went downstairs to look at it.
I was like,
oh boy.
Oh boy.
What'd you look at?
Dead floor.
You can eat off.
Oh boy.
And I went in there,
boom,
ba boom,
ba was bubbles.
So they got to add another layer because you know my floor is not level at all.
His fucking shed.
We've got to float the floor.
That's going to cost you all this money.
Maybe you fill in the cracks,
but
now the grand out the window say I don't even care anymore.
I just laugh now.
When contractors come up to me,
what do you,
what do you want?
What do you like?
It's like that old Robin Williams story that if you just walked up to him at
some point you said,
hey man,
I'm Robin.
I'm a comedian.
He would just write you a check for 100 bucks.
They,
sorry.
Sorry.
If I riffed on some of your shit,
my apologies.
This is what I do now with contract to show up.
Yeah,
I want to,
yeah,
I know.
Well,
how much time can I just go into my pocket?
Oh,
do I need the checkbook?
Do I got to write numbers on a piece of paper just never ends.
It never ends.
And meanwhile,
meanwhile,
as I wait for the gym to be made,
I am sitting in the writer's room doing f is for family and two things have
happened.
I'm,
I'm putting on writer's room.
Wait,
my gym is in fucking made at,
uh,
you know,
I'm fucking,
uh,
I felt like the last,
I don't know if I've talked to you guys about my fucking left leg,
my hamstrings tighten up.
You know,
you ever see the guy run down the first base line and I'll say,
hey,
starts fucking hoppin.
Oh,
that guy in the Celtics and game one year run it up the court.
He just fucking collapses.
I was like,
oh,
did I,
did I literally pull a hamstring doing stand up because God knows I haven't been
working out.
And um,
and you know what,
I ended up figuring it out.
What it was is a,
it's from sitting down in the fucking writer's room.
Like,
I guess sitting is not healthy.
It's one of the most unhealthy things she could do.
I guess you body's not designed the way that we set the way that we've made
chairs.
Just plop your ass down,
whatever it is,
blood flow.
I don't know what the fuck it is.
So all fucking Billy Budd cheeks here.
Now I've got a problem with my fucking sciatic nerve on my left side.
So I literally had to have my lovely wife buy one of those foam rollers,
right?
It's just how all the way up is from Siddiq all right.
And you,
you literally,
I looked up some lay on the fucking internet who had like,
I looked up the proper way to do it before I did it because I know that you can
fuck you body up.
Like people get these things and they just start rolling around on them.
And I immediately learned first thing,
you don't want to roll over joints as all this shit and is all this proper form.
So I went through about two or three videos.
So I got to somebody who all the comments were like,
oh my God,
your form's perfect and all that.
So I was,
I was watching this woman.
So basically what I do is I sit down on the thing and then cross my legs is she
says cowboy style,
not lady like cowboy style,
which is basically like if I was wearing a skirt,
my balls would be hanging out.
Right.
Sorry for the visual.
Um,
you sit like that and then you sort of put your weight on one side and you,
and I got to tell you,
dude,
the fucking pain that I was in,
it isn't like a,
uh,
it,
it isn't like a,
like a severe pain.
It was like the,
if you had an older brother and you know when he would be fucking with you and
he,
I sorta start twisting your arm,
you'd be like,
ah,
like that,
that type of a fucking paint.
And um,
I got to tell you that the,
the foam roller is a goddamn game changer when,
if I didn't have to go in.
But the thing is I kind of work it out and it's fine.
Hey,
work it out,
you know?
But then I go and I'm in a writer's room all day,
so I keep trying to stand up and that type of shit and I'm feeling like it's two
steps forward and one step back,
but I'm at least moving in the right direction.
So I just putting that out there.
If you do,
um,
have any of those types of problems,
uh,
get one of those.
This has been working for me.
I should say.
I'm not a doctor and I don't play one on TV,
but this has been working for me.
And if you're young,
uh,
I would start doing yoga is soon.
She can,
it's,
I'm telling you,
I,
I've known this forever,
but I just get bored with Shit.
I'll do yoga and be like,
I'm just going to do Joe.
Good give we book a day and then I just get burned out and then I'm like,
you know what?
Fuck Yoga.
You know,
I get mad at yoga rather than myself for being totally fucking obsessed with
shit for like 10 days until I just,
you know,
I did that with chipotle a long time ago when I lived in New York City.
You know,
if you have a move to New York City,
which I hope you do,
everybody should try fucking live there.
It's great.
You know,
until you get into your thirties and it's like,
oh,
am I going to be one of those cat people?
I gotta get Outta here,
right?
I want some space,
you know?
Um,
but when you live there,
you know,
you start ordering out does how it works and you move there,
you're fucking terrified.
Like,
how the fuck am I going to afford to live here?
And you fucking eat spaghetti every fucking night,
right?
And then you start making a little more money and every once in a while you take
a cab and you're like,
oh my God,
I'm taking a cab.
This is fucking amazing.
And then he'd get back to your apartment and you have all this guilt because you
blew all that money.
And you could have just spent,
you know,
whatever the fuck it was back in the day,
it was like a dollar 25 to take the subway.
Yeah,
I know.
That's how old I am.
Um,
and then you start making it a little more than money.
Then all of a sudden you start ordering out,
right?
He started ordering it out.
You start to get to know all the restaurants and all that type of shit.
And then when she had the money to order out,
what immediately happens is,
is this a radius within which that they'll deliver and you burn out every
fucking restaurant around you and then you become,
then you're officially in New Yorker when you're living in Manhattan and you're
bitching that there's no good restaurants in your neighborhood.
There's no good to town and you can't get good Italian.
I don't understand why.
I mean,
there's so many people here.
It'd be the foot traffic.
Alo,
why don't they put in it an Italian fucking restaurant?
And he started flipping out like,
whatever your favorite food is,
you bitching that it's not there.
Um,
so whatever.
So this chipotle ends up opening up after I tried every fucking restaurant 15
times in my little fucking three block radius.
And I went to that fucking thing.
Like I swear to God,
I went there like,
I dunno,
maybe 11 days in a month.
I will never forget how I felt that last time.
I felt like I was at the end of like a food eating contests where you were just
telling your jaw to keep moving up and down with the rest of your body was like,
can we just a puke now?
And um,
I don't think I've ever,
I don't think I've been this sense chipolte lay and Thai food.
It was a Thai food restaurant down the street.
And I remember I ordered it and it was delicious.
And then it sat in my fridge for two,
three days and I said,
hey,
you know what I think I do.
I'll do what I'm going to eat that three day you'll Thai food,
see how that does.
And I got food poisoning.
And,
um,
rather than being the mature person and taking the responsibility on my end,
I blame Thai food.
I was like,
Fuck Thai food,
I'm never eating Thai food again.
And I didn't eat that for like 10 years.
And then,
uh,
you know,
eventually became back.
We were a,
we were able to smooth things over,
you know,
like guns n roses,
you know what I mean?
It was exact same thing,
exact same trajectory I had with Thai food,
um,
band members and guns and roses head with axl rose and now they're all back
together and evidently the fucking shows have been great.
Um,
they played in Mexico City the other night and uh,
I would have loved to have gone down to that,
going to that show,
had a great time,
then get kidnapped,
you know,
when that'd be great.
Mexico City scares the shit out of me.
And He,
Mexico people,
Mexicans,
real ones,
real ones.
I don't mean the one's here in la.
I mean,
the real fucking deal.
You're in Mexico,
you know what I mean?
Like,
I'm German Irish,
but I don't live in Deutschland or fucking the,
the emerald aisle.
You know what I mean?
I lived in Massachusetts,
I went to friendly's.
You know,
I'm not a crowd,
right?
So let me,
let,
let me ask you this,
because it's right there.
It's fucking a quick plane right away.
There's all these beautiful places to go.
And then there's all these other fucked up places to go.
I don't know where to go.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
all they show about you guys is the fucking drug cartels peeling people's faces
back.
You know,
and I know there's no fucking way all of Mexico,
everybody's just walking around,
peeling off each other's faces.
I know there's no fucking way that that's happening.
I know there's,
it's like here,
I bet people outside of this country think everybody walks down the street with
a fucking gun on their hip.
You know,
when they don't have money for a tall,
they shoot the guy in the toll booths.
And then some stage coach comes in,
I don't know what the fuck they think.
Right?
Or they think we're and,
and we're all 300 pounds and we're on fucking meth.
Right?
We don't know where England is.
I'll let shell like that snobby European shit where they just think they're so
fucking cultured.
You know what I mean?
With their little ass fucking countries over there that's driving own.
Am I going to fucking Europe?
I love when they say shit like that.
You know,
you guys don't know about the fucking world.
It's like neither do you.
You don't know what the fuck's going on over in Asia.
Okay.
You know what's going on,
right?
And your little fucking area,
but you're a little area for me would just be the east coast.
But for you it's like 15 different fucking countries.
Belgium and fucking Luxembourg.
I mean,
you can walk through those two countries so you can sleep,
walk through those two countries from fucking Amsterdam and ended up in France
and be like,
Whoa,
what happened?
I'll have shit.
I got to go to work and then jog back.
Um,
having said that,
I'd love to go to both places.
Oh,
the big phony covered his fucking tracks.
I was gonna go to your show in Belgium.
But after you talked about how small we were.
No,
I'm not going,
um,
controversy on social media today when one person in Belgium took offense.
Um,
so anyways,
they redoing the fucking floors again.
So I ended up getting bubbles.
Okay.
B is four bubbles over that.
Sesame Street,
bubbles,
it painful.
Probably Hoopla.
Some of that was that fucking guy with the puberty voice harmonizing.
I think it was supposed to sound like a beach boy type thing,
but it didn't,
it was just fucking,
he used to make me like angry when I was a kid.
See if I can find that for you guys and I'll start playing it.
Okay.
Um,
so anyways,
as always,
I never let myself get too out of shape and I need to drop about 10 pounds.
So I'm Oh fucking,
uh,
freckles here despite the fact I,
the gym isn't made yet and I got to go to work every day.
I'm going to try to lose two pounds a week back up to one 80.
Everybody and I been eating well the last couple of days and always the first
couple of days.
The fact that the just eat well you drop a couple.
So I got on the scale yesterday,
said one 77,
so I must have ate like a fucking tuberous shit the night before when I got on
at one eight about [inaudible] 78.
So I'm just going to go back down to one 68.
Um,
he right around the time for my birthday and uh,
you know,
two pounds.
That's easy,
right?
A couple of push ups,
you know what I mean?
I'll go on my stupid foam roller.
Oh my God.
I,
you know what,
I'm so fucking old.
I think I have to bring it to work.
Yeah.
How fucking hilarious.
I said I'm going to walk in with that thing at work and,
and I'm going to walk in to a room full of comedy writers.
Does he drew understand the pounding that I'm going to fucking take.
Let me get,
oh,
that's going to actually fuck up our work for today.
Cause they're going to spend the first two hours trashing me.
Um,
and what am I going to do other than fucking take it?
That's it.
There's nothing I can fucking do.
Oh,
by the way,
is I'm all over the fucking map here.
Did you fucking see that?
Shameless fucking Hillary Clinton
trying to pander to get the African American vote.
She's on some radio show.
I just watched a clip.
I had to shut it off.
Forgive me.
I don't know what radio show it is,
but she's sitting there.
She goes and she's trying to get the black vote and she,
they asked you what's something you always carry around with you?
And she said,
hot sauce.
The Clintons are the fucking,
I swear to God.
Okay.
Can't you just see both of them on a used car lot to one of those cheesy local
commercials?
Do they had the fucking devil?
Okay.
I remember when Hillary Clinton ran for fucking,
uh,
Senate after eight years of being in the White House to fucking Yankees said
one,
four world series.
She never showed up,
never said a fucking thing.
And then all of a sudden she's running for fucking a Senate in New York,
shows up with a brand new Yaggie head and goes,
I've always been a Yankee fan.
And then this big grand,
like I said it now they're going to like me.
This is how out of touch she is.
She literally thinks that she just has to say,
I carry around hot sauce
and all,
all black people are going to be like,
oh shit.
Oh,
I can relate to that.
What's she gonna do next?
You get to go to fucking Chinatown,
which I always carry around soy sauce.
Yeah,
go down south.
You know,
I love guns and my cousin's,
sorry,
I shouldn't have said that.
Um,
hot rods.
I've always liked hot rods.
Fucking shameless.
This is the thing about like when you're at her level of fucking wealth,
which is really,
I don't know how you explain it.
You know,
when her husband,
you know,
had the highest office in public office and you only is president,
you only make four,
500 grand a year.
Somehow they through their daughter a $3 million wedding.
I mean,
how does the math work there?
Okay,
they are the fuck she is the fucking devil.
I'm telling you.
You know,
oh my God,
what a fucking selection this year.
Can you fucking believe this shit?
A reality show star.
You know who's sitting there with that fucking,
I don't know what the other guy's name is now talking about the size of their
hands to heaven had did size of your dick debate running for office.
You got Hilary.
You fucking write it.
I'll say it.
She doesn't give a fuck.
This is why I gotta be honest with you.
Why I like Republicans better than Democrats because the Republicans at least
have the decency to just show,
to openly show you that they don't give a fuck about you and Democrats.
They actually tried to act like they give a fuck how people about people who
work for a fucking living.
They don't did the same fucking people.
They just lie about it.
You know?
I swear to God,
if Bernie Sanders would just fucking gold the hallway,
you know what I mean?
Don't stop and Kuwait,
you got to go all the way to Baghdad with these fucking bankers.
Okay?
That's what you gotta do.
You gotta tip over the statue when you got to have all those top level bankers
swinging at the end of a rope.
That's the only way to stick out a start over again.
That's my candidate.
None of them are saying that.
So it's over.
And I know you're thinking bill,
you don't know shit.
And you read conspiracy theory and you know what I say to that?
You're absolutely right.
Okay.
All right,
let's move on.
That was,
uh,
that was,
that was political comedy right there,
if you will.
If you're wondering what that was supposed to be,
she goes to little Italy.
What do you always have in your purse?
A jar of Marinara sauce.
Who's your favorite singer?
Dean Martin.
Oh my God.
Did you see the house?
She looked like she rolled her eyes.
I don't want to put like shit on her that,
that's what she fucking did.
That's how out of touch she is.
Hillary Clinton thinks black.
All black people walk around with hot sauce in their purse because white people
don't know how to season food.
Uh,
I'm not saying there aren't some black people to do that,
you know what I mean?
But you know,
that would also be people who aren't white who look at white people and think
we're all in the upper 1% standing on a yard shooting the shit with one of the
Kennedy's and they're fucking weird in Brendan inbred dentition.
I never understood the Kennedys.
I,
they,
they're from like the nose up.
They're really good looking people,
great hair,
you know,
nice fucking big five head,
it looks great on TV,
decent eyes,
you know,
and then you just get to that,
you get to those,
those,
I mean it was getting hot.
They look like from the nose down,
they look like Clint Howard.
I don't know what it is.
There's something going on with that family.
You can't,
yeah.
You know what it is,
is they still look ethnic.
They feel look at,
um,
yeah.
If you look at like,
like white people from like,
like look at Joe Dimaggio,
you,
he's probably considered a good looking guy.
That guy is fucking deck.
I Dunno what happened once everybody got all mixed up like all the fucking Nash
and I was getting mixed up like dino started streamlining the looks and people
are way better looking now.
Don't you think then when you look back in the day,
I mean Jesus Christ,
Babe Ruth every once in Lou Gehrig was a good looking guy.
You know what I mean?
But Babe Ruth that I was a mess.
Joe Dimaggio mess.
I guess they weren't all bad looking.
I don't know.
I'm just saying when you look at the shit back then,
like an Italian guy looked a hundred percent fucking,
I don't,
you know something.
And when I went to Italy they were better look in the back then,
I don't know what the fuck it was.
We allegedly had better food back then.
People were shorter.
I don't know what it was.
Did you ever notice that when you look back and when you really look at those
old pictures?
I love looking at old pictures and it's like that George Carlin bit,
when you look at an old picture and you're like,
everybody in that picture is dead.
And for some reason in a morbid way,
it's like fascinating.
When I look at those old pictures,
I just,
that's what I think a God damn it.
There was some fucking ugly ass people,
you know,
and you know,
it was a game changer was uh,
three things.
Polio,
vaccine,
penicillin and braces.
Those three fucking things could just hide so many fucking imperfections,
you know what I mean?
And once you get braces,
Jesus Christ,
if you just brush your fucking teeth in remotely,
keep yourself in shape.
You know,
you throw on some nice clothes.
People have no idea where you came from.
You know,
back in the day,
people,
they saw it on your teeth,
told the whole fucking story.
You just smile and be like,
hi,
I can,
I can see you're going to have tuberculosis.
You live in a damp Dag fucking apartment with no fucking windows.
You saw it in their fucking teeth,
right?
I don't know about it.
Heard.
What's his face?
Jp Morgan had like Rosacea.
Is that how you say they're all over his face?
He was just all fucking angry.
Those old school rich guys,
you know,
he used to walk around with top hats,
just like the penguin harm while walking down the street.
Um,
is this a podcast every morning?
I don't even,
what the fuck I'm talking about?
Let me,
let me do some advertising here and then I'll uh,
I'll get to more babbling here in a moment.
All right.
Hot Sauce.
A shameless fucking shameless.
She looks in,
bred her fucking teeth.
There's something going on with Tara on the sub.
Go with you.
See how Bill Clinton collapse now it's like he's a,
like a marionette puppet.
He has his mouth open.
That's how he made it.
But that smiling with his mouth open.
Oh,
I'm going to fix it.
I don't know.
Fix everything.
How you doing?
Call me later.
Oh,
I'm all right on it.
Everybody on it.
This company,
the Great Joe Rogan.
This is his company here at speaking of getting into shape,
a lot of people when they in shape,
what do they do?
They do set ups,
right?
They do fucking,
they do a pull ups.
They do push ups.
They do all the upper body stuff and they walk around with their fucking chicken
legs.
But still you're always working on the outside of your body.
What about the inside man?
Well,
thank God this on it.
Alpha brain instant from Onnit.
Is it delicious?
All natural stimulant free drink mix that helps support memory,
focus and processing speed.
The Boston Center for men or memory conducted a double blind studies showing its
effectiveness.
That's pretty impressive,
Huh?
It's the secret weapon of pro athletes like I'm gonna fuck these names of Bodie
Miller,
Brian Cushing and Jonathan tapes.
But anyone can benefit from the effects of Alpha brain instant.
Speaking of that,
what about the blues?
Huh?
Up three games to one.
All right.
Simple mixes is a stick.
Oh,
simply mix is a stick packet of Alpha brain instant into a water bottle.
simply mix a stick.
Oh my God,
I need this shit.
You know what I should do?
I should start taking this shit and then he could hear are much better.
I read the copy then you guys would fast forward to through it because there'd
be no reason to.
Listen to me fucking this up.
Simply mix a stick packet of Alpha brain instant into a water bottle and start
feeling the effects immediately.
It's non Gmo,
nice gluten free,
sweet stimulant,
free made of natural ingredients and most importantly it works.
And as a special offer for my listeners,
you can try alpha brain instant for free by going to Onnit,
o n n I t on it.com/burr,
that's o n n I t.com/burr to get your free sample of Alpha brain instant.
Now you know what?
I think I got to do that.
I'm worried that that would fuck up everything.
That makes me funny.
You know,
we knew it was kidding who most of the reason why he left.
It makes them a fucking dope.
But what if I just take it?
I'm smart for a few weeks and then you guys see that it works.
And then I just stopped taking it and I go back to being stupid again.
And then you guys could send me emails like,
hey bill,
remember when you were fucking SMAD?
All right,
score big score big everybody.
You're paying too much for tickets between all the mockups and lists and last
minute convenience charges,
which aren't convenient except for the people who get the money.
Even printed home fees.
You end up paying courtside prices for nosebleed seats and that's bullshit.
Scored big is here to change that.
Did you know that 40% of all live event tickets go on sold?
And did you know here there's a place to get these seats at a huge savings.
It's called ScoreBig.
Scorebig works directly with your favorite teams and artists to get their unsold
seats at unpublished prices.
Only with score big.
Can you name a ticket price and be guaranteed to pay below box office up to 60%
off.
Here's what you do.
One,
go to score big.com or download the new score.
Big App on for your iPhone.
And finally event.
And CICI want to make an offer with score.
Biggs name a ticket price feature nine,
sorry.
Three get an instant answer and save up to 60% of your tickets.
Never any fees.
And shipping is always free.
You can count on unbeatable prices and great seats.
And when you're in great seats,
you actually enjoy the game or show all the more.
Next time you go to see any game or show,
go to score big first and see how much you can save for the easiest way to save
on tickets.
Download the new score.
Big App for your iPhone.
Enter Promo Code Burr at the checkout and you'll save an extra 20 bucks for your
first ticket purchase.
Now iPhone,
no problem.
Get $20 off online at ScoreBig Dotcom,
that score big.com promo code bar.
Hey,
score big.com Promo Code Burr.
Okay,
I still don't get that.
I really don't.
I don't understand that that the fucking 40% of the tickets go on sold.
So like when the patriots,
everybody wants a Patriot's ticket's,
only 40% of those tickets go and sold.
I,
I really don't understand that part of it.
This is why I lose advertising.
Um,
it shouldn't just question to question if you'll just read it.
Go into advertising mode,
Boll and branch as you set out to prove yourself.
There is one simple thing you could do every day to help you.
Uh,
you be your best in every situation and that's getting a good night's sleep.
Boll and branch delivers the rest you need wrapped up in their super comfortable
luxury linens and they do it right there.
The first betting company to be fair trade certified,
which means that your sheets come from the work of happy hands,
not sweatshops.
Nice.
Ah,
somebody who finally cares about other human beings,
nice and beautiful packaging made entirely from recycled and some sustainable
materials.
There's companies doing it right.
Um,
you can only get their sheets in one place.
That's Boll and branch.com where you know you're paying for quality and not to
start department store overhead.
You also know that no crying child made it at three o'clock in the morning.
Um,
you're getting thousands of thousand dollars sheets for just a couple of hundred
bucks.
Go online to bowl,
that's B o,
l l and branch.com like cliff.
And they'll let you transfer rate offense and they let you try them.
Risk free for 30 days.
If you don't love them,
you could send them back.
You have nothing to lose and it gets even better.
Go to bold and branch.com today for 20% off your entire order sheets,
towels,
blankets,
duvet covers everything.
Extra bonus points.
I said,
do vague properly plus free shipping.
Um,
and all their products come beautifully packaged in their signature box sets.
Go to bolden branch.com today for 20% off your entire order and use Promo Code,
Burr Boll and branch.com Promo Code Barb Boll and branch.com Promo Code Burr
Jesus fucking Christ.
I still have two more.
We're not,
I can't do two.
I'll do two more later.
Let's go back to here.
Um,
the fucking,
how about the Saint Louis Blues?
Me in Saint Louis,
meet me yet the fair,
um,
I miss game three.
I was convinced that a,
once they blew game to that,
that was fucking it.
Um,
but I was actually able to watch game four and um,
I worry when I turned,
I actually turned it on mid second,
mid second period.
And um,
yeah,
I got to tell you that these are not your fucking dance.
St Louis Blues,
you know,
they were down,
they came back,
they went ahead.
They just,
they just,
it's actually you're watching Chicago losing their composure.
Chicago trying to draw them into fights and stuff like that.
It's unbelievable.
Now.
I'm not counting,
I kind of am cotton Chicago.
I don't think that they are going to come back from this one.
I think a St Louis Blues are a got their eye on the prize or whatever.
I think they got the series and um,
just the way they're playing,
just all the shit that they,
I've seen them go through all these years and never answered the bell and just
fucking implode and lose the fucking series there.
This team does not do that.
And,
uh,
it's fucking great to see,
but it's also great watching the Blackhawks to like,
you know,
what I love about them is you can see like their,
their,
um,
like Patrick King and you could just see the guy gives a fuck.
That's the ego win one championship.
And that'd be like,
yeah,
you know,
fucking whatever.
But the guys who give a fuck and they want to win as many as they can,
he can't put a price on those guys.
So as much as it's kind of bizarre watching Chicago being down three to one
after this success over the last five,
six years,
um,
watching how much they give a fuck,
who is that?
And I mean,
I'm so bad with the names down,
so out of the fucking loop,
who's the guy,
uh,
Patrick Sharp,
get fucking trade it.
Who was,
the guy was fucking crosscheck and everybody at the end of the game and it was a
go the guys at dirty piece of shit.
It's like,
no,
he isn't.
He gives a fuck.
He gives a fuck,
you know,
going to the penalty box.
He's fucking screaming at people dropping the F bomb.
I loved every second of it.
Um,
oh man.
You know,
you know what?
I shouldn't even say the Blackhawks arrived the keys.
You know the fucking Black Hawks right now.
I like this no fucking way.
These guys are going to beat us next game.
You know that.
That's what they're saying.
Fuck this shit.
All we need to do is when this next one get it back into our building and then
the pressure will be on them.
That all,
fuck if we don't,
we don't win this one then.
Now we're looking at a game seven.
That's how fucked up three to one is.
You always think like,
Oh man was sitting pretty and it's just like,
no,
we're not.
We're not.
We have to win this next game.
If we lose this next game,
then all of a sudden all of the fucking pressure is dumped on us for the next,
for the rest of the series.
Um,
it's,
I dunno,
it's fucking a,
okay.
I Dunno.
I actually believe it or not as bad as I am at math,
like seven game series numbers like fascinate me.
Like if you go down,
oh to like the Boston Celtics and it's this weird thing where if you just think
look,
which is down two games to none,
it doesn't seem that bad.
A hole to crawl out of.
But when you do the math and be like we have to win four of the remaining five
games,
you're like what the fuck?
How the fuck do you do that?
And you know when I say the [inaudible] 86 mets,
cause I remember that we won the first two games in New York City and I was just
like Oh my God,
all we got to do is when to one of the next four they got to win four out of the
next,
I'm sorry we got to win two out of the next five.
Okay.
That's all we had to do.
Oh,
we had to deal with with two out of the next five to one four to five and they
fuck,
they came back and they won game three and four and Fenway,
if I remember this correctly,
the first two games wasn't a down there.
I don't,
I know what,
I can't remember that.
I just remember we won the first two games and I want to say they came here
and then what that would do if they were here.
Then we went down there,
don't game six and seven went down there.
Game six certainly was and seven was,
wait,
hold on.
A fuck.
Should go.
It goes home.
Home away.
Away.
Oh my way home.
No,
maybe it was his three in a row in Boston.
Okay.
Maybe it was three in a row and bottom.
They might've gone to three.
Two,
yeah.
Oh God.
What a shit show.
We won game five were like,
finally we had games six one we blew that and then we were up three.
Nothing gave seminar.
It can be,
it can be all,
but just like fucking that.
So I really shouldn't say this is over.
All I'm saying is you've got to watch game five and you watch how the fucking
black hawks come up.
I know that they lost a lot of guys,
but they still got tapes.
They still got a fucking dog a k days still God fuck.
And the other guy and the other fucking guy,
right?
You got enough guys left data like we're not losing this fucking game.
Um,
blues.
You know what is,
I think it's a must win.
You have to meet just saying,
this is how fucking wishy washy I am after I just say,
I think the blue got this one.
I'm,
I'm not thinking like,
thank God they got to close your mouth.
Okay,
I got close.
My Jesus Christ,
I hope in new Gingrich looking coach fucking gives them that speech.
Um,
speaking to which the Boston Celtics,
I'm calling it right now.
Hot before you get to fucking excited.
I'm going Joe Willie name.
It's right now.
I guarantee fucking t you the Boston Celtics.
You're going to go into the garden.
There's going to be all those championship banners hanging from the fucking
rafters,
right?
All of a sudden you're not gonna have that cool breeze blowing over your head
like you feel down in your Omni Center.
Whatever the fuck the hawks play right from your lack of goddamn championships
down there.
Um,
the Boston Celtics,
I am me who doesn't play hoop?
Who isn't a professional athlete?
Okay?
Who cannot read out loud is Guaran fucking team.
The Boston Celtics are going to win game three.
I'm calling it right fucking now.
If I don't understand why you have to wait till fucking Friday.
I'm actually going to be on the road.
Were you going to be bill?
I'm going to be in Saint Louis,
the original home of the Atlanta Hawks,
the Saint Louis Hawks and who beat him in 1958 for the NBA Championship.
The Boston Celtics.
You like dead.
The synergies all going to be there.
They're going back to Boston where all those championship banners are.
Old Billy red face is going to be in Saint Louis,
the original home of the hearts where we beat them in 1958 and I'm telling you
right now,
you take all your money,
you steal from your mother,
you put it on the Celtics,
and I guarantee you you're going to come away a winner.
And if you lose,
I don't want to hear you crying to me because I take no responsibility for this.
All right?
You're responsible for your own fucking actions are the most fucked up thought.
Okay,
I had the most fucking fucked up thought the other night and I,
and you happen to have like a fucked up thought and then you did,
you go to Google it and you thinking like a bunch of people going to agree with
you and then you're just like,
no,
you know what?
I'm just a fucking moron.
You know that postpartum depression,
you know,
women have a baby and then they just fucking have this unbelievable level of
depression.
Um,
I whatever,
for whatever reason,
was hearing a story about it and I was listening and listening and I was
thinking like,
you know what?
As much as that is a thing,
uh,
I bet 17%,
I dunno why it came to that number,
but in my head,
17% of women that get postpartum depression,
that just,
that's what I was thinking.
Like it's a real thing for 83% of them,
but 17% of them are just mad now that they have a kid and they can't go out and
go do Jello shots whenever they want to.
And then it just being a bunch of fucking babies about it.
That's what old not doctor [inaudible] was thinking.
And then I looked it up and there was all this fucking shit about dumb men like
me that thinks shit like that.
So you know what's great is I only thought that thought for about three minutes
and then I went and looked it up and I was like,
oh,
all right,
I'm a moron,
I'm a moron.
I wonder if there's any male,
if there's male male,
can males have that shit?
Don't even bother doing studies.
They don't give a fuck about us.
They just,
we don't,
we die eight years before women on average,
and they,
nobody really cares.
They,
why does this keep happening?
They don't give a fuck.
Yeah.
It's a guy.
I'll make another one.
All right.
Um,
male post partum.
Oh my God.
There is this
facts about men depression.
Oh,
give me a fucking break.
You didn't go through and he's fucking sort of physical thing.
The kid has guys who want to the game anymore.
Um,
men's depression research is only beginning to understand men's unique
experiences of depression.
Yeah.
You,
why?
Why do you think that is?
Because we're told to shut the fuck up and plow through it.
Uh,
blah,
blah.
Research is lagging even further as for PP and d,
whatever that is.
I don't know what that is.
Postpartum Notre Dame,
I don't have no idea.
Um,
in terms of depression in general,
if you're a man,
you're more likely than a woman to try and hide your depression or to withdraw
from others.
This only worsens your system.
Oh,
paternal posts post natal depression.
Oh my God,
you should see the pictures of these fucking people.
This guy's sitting there.
He's,
he's clearly an actor and he's just looking down.
Holding is like pinching his nose between his eyes.
Okay.
In this picture we want you to look depressed.
All right?
You know that statue?
The thinker.
Okay.
I want you to do the same pose,
but don't think I want you to pinch the top of your nose.
That's it.
Close your eyes.
Think of something painful and all right,
that's it.
Here's 50 bucks.
Go get you something to donuts.
Classic symptoms of depression.
Depressed,
sad mood.
All right,
let's,
I'm going to take this test.
Uh,
depressed,
sad mood.
Ah,
no,
I don't have that.
Loss of interest or pleasure.
I don't have that either.
Significant ways.
Loss or gain.
Fuck,
I'm putting on weight.
I have this shit.
Trouble sleeping and oversleeping.
Oh No,
I thought it was the booze.
Restless feeling and inability to sit still or slow down.
Yeah,
I definitely got that fatigue.
Loss of energy.
Tower tired all the time.
Absolutely.
I thought that was,
cause I drink every night.
And you only get four hours sleep,
worthless or guilty feelings check a impaired concentration at difficulty making
decisions.
I got half of that.
Recurrent thoughts of death or suicide.
Yep.
Um,
suicide options is always right there,
right?
It's such an easy one.
You dislike,
you know,
or I could just kill myself.
No,
but then you know what if,
uh,
what of the Bruins rebuild it.
I miss it.
You know what I think I'll stick around.
Um,
all right,
let me,
uh,
let me read a little more of this.
The uh,
the advertising here,
they'll gracefully get the fuck outta here for him to go to the right.
Oh Jesus.
But beyond these
Biondi yeah,
motherfucking kid.
But it'll do
Biondi is Biondi
blew it in or that's what you did and now you feel bad cause you,
you're my fucking man.
Caves got a baby crib and you want a booze every time you see that kid,
no matter how much you fucking love it,
you still want to booze.
Thank God you're fucking balls are dry.
We really beat it.
All right,
me.
These,
whether you're wearing a suit or sweats,
you spend almost 24 hours a day in your underwear,
but instead of making a statement like Superman's tights under his everyday
clothes,
your underwear is probably boring me undies is here to change that.
Everybody,
every pair of me undies is made from a sustainable source modal,
a fabric that is twice as soft as cotton says,
the makers of mod out.
Nothing can describe the fit and feel of me undies.
But once you try them on,
you'll understand why they're called the world's most comfortable underwear.
I'm going to wear underwear,
and if you don't love the first pair of me undies,
they're free.
No questions asked.
Roundy's has dozens of styles and limited edition prints to help you make a
statement with your underwear,
whether anyone can see them or not.
Remember,
remember superman?
All right.
Shipping is free in the U S and Canada and you can save up to $8 a pair with the
me on the subscription plan.
Get the subscription or a single pair and get 20% off your first order.
When you go to me,
undies.com/bird.
That's me.
[inaudible] dot com slash [inaudible] for 20% off your first order.
Hi me,
Andy's dot com slash bar.
All right.
The last one,
uh,
legal zone,
five things you can count on when using legal zoom for.
Dude,
how much do you shit yourself that you got to have a subscription to get
underwear?
Good Lord,
he fucking wet dream Wally.
Alright.
Legal Zoom.
Five things you can count on when using legal zoom for your business.
Number one,
numero oh re reliability.
More than a reliability.
More than a million people have already trusted legal zone.
Just start help start their businesses and corporations,
LLCs,
nonprofits,
DBH and more.
Use Legal Zoom to get started the right way.
Number two,
experience.
You can count on Lou legal zoom for all the details.
They've been helping all types of business owners for 15 years.
Number three,
helpful support.
Uh,
they have the right people standing by ready to help you with your questions.
All based in the U.
S do you think I'm pretty?
Of course you are.
Says Legal Zoom number four,
numero quatro.
Uh,
legal advice.
Legal Zoom isn't a law firm,
so they built a network of independent attorneys available in 48 states.
You'll get answers to your legal questions and they can review supplier
contracts,
employment laws,
and help with most of the day to day situations that pop up.
And finally,
number five,
um,
Uno dos tres quatro.
Cinco,
the block tap sank a number five,
a no surprises.
Legal Zoom provides complete transparency with upfront pricing and customer
reviews with a hundred percent satisfaction guarantee.
Make the smart choice for your businesses@legalzoom.com today.
And don't forget to enter Burr at checkout to save even more,
uh,
at legal zoom.com.
There you go.
All right.
And you know what,
that's the first half of the podcast here.
And,
uh,
I want to thank all the African Americans who are listening to this and I want
you to know that,
um,
you know,
my favorite guilty pleasure is soul food.
Uh,
Eddie Asians listening.
Um,
I don't know.
I uh,
I really respect mixed martial arts.
Good.
Try to appeal to everybody.
Germans,
I don't hold you responsible for why you picked one bad guy.
You know,
you had a bad fucking couple of years.
All of a sudden the wrong guy got in there.
You,
it happens eventually.
It happens to every country.
I mean,
I think at this point,
hasn't there been a mass murdering maniac?
I'm,
you know,
haven't the Germans made enough unbelievable sports,
sedans,
Porsche's,
you know?
No,
you don't think so.
They got nice clothes,
so don't they?
I don't fucking know.
Anyways,
I don't know what to do.
Thank you.
Jeremy.
I you guys during the World Cup.
How about that?
It's just funny that I like listening.
If there's something funny to me of a bunch of Germans in public,
in a stadium,
you know,
singing along and shit that no,
there's no way that's never not going to be creepy anymore.
So there's just something hilarious about it.
So I always root for you guys to get to the later rounds,
you know?
And as you like when Germany,
whatever they're playing like Brazil,
it's impossible to not pictured the ghost of fucking Adolf Hitler's sitting up
there hoping for a do over Jesse Owens embarrassed them and you know,
you think he's not up there best two out of three.
Um,
right.
Please enjoy this music and we're going to start blogging and play some greatest
hits from a Monday morning podcast gone.
Bye.
Thank you everybody.
You have a great weekend,
your cuts.
And uh,
once again,
thank you to everybody who's been watching.
F is for family.
We are having a great time writing these things.
And last night we had a great event with Netflix.
Netflix.
Keep it weird.
They did this thing.
They hijack that hippy fucking thing.
Yeah,
they're corporation.
You know what I mean?
They do want to.
Hillary Clinton does.
You know what's the one thing you have on you at all times?
Netflix.
Oh,
I always have a bag of weed and my purse,
man,
everybody's running for office.
All right,
that's it.
Go fuck yourselves.
I've talked to you on Monday.
Hello.
What's going on Monday morning.
And as she can tell by the sound of my voice,
uh,
I got about two hours sleep less last night I was sitting in the continental
terminal in Newark Airport.
I just had an Omelet,
fucking three cheese and a got damn piece of toast and a,
I was trying not to get mad at the guy making the fucking ex,
but I did order toast with it,
you know?
And uh,
I don't know if this has been your experience,
but my experience is when I go into a breakfast establishment,
every time you order something,
hang on a second.
Okay?
Yeah.
Got It.
I got it out of that.
We know,
we know.
We know we have to get on the airplane.
Got Up
please.
All old people.
Do we have a lamp and get on first?
We know how it works.
Shut up.
Okay.
Anyway,
so when I order,
uh,
anytime I go out to breakfast place right now,
I ordered toast.
He gotta get toast with your eggs.
You know,
you're a fucking communist.
Okay.
Perfect sense fucking reason.
They always make the goddamn x first and then they go,
oh shit,
I didn't make the toast.
So then either they give you the eggs and you eat the fucking eggs without the
toast,
which once again is unamerican eat the toast with the fucking ax.
It's supposed to arrive at the same time.
Okay,
so you did just give you the goddamn eggs and he can fucking eggs.
And then they go,
oh,
by the way,
he or she tells,
you know,
have you ever give you ordered like a hot fudge Sundae and it gave you the
fucking ice cream.
And then once your daddy get me ice cream,
then they came over with the,
with the fuck,
but they could shout out a hot fudge.
You know,
when you hold your nose,
you get to fucking throw it down like Yeager muster,
you know?
So this fucking Douche bag makes the goddamn eggs.
All right.
And then realize,
oh,
you white toast with that.
Yeah,
he had toast with that.
Do you read the next line on the fucking order slip?
You would've seen it.
You know,
it's not like it's,
it's,
it's a lot of reading.
It's not war and peace.
It says three cheese omelets and underneath it it said white toast.
Right.
So what,
what does this guy do?
He ops it,
keep the fucking eggs
with him while he waits for the toast to be done and he's making some sort of
Turkey sandwich.
And a needless to say,
I get,
I get the egg.
Oh,
it's just loud.
Fucking going to be screaming at her cell phone near me.
You know,
I tried to pick up fucking part of the airport where no one would come.
Okay.
She got on a tracks,
it got 11 old person and attracts,
um,
you know what I mean?
What are they doing?
Are we union up in 1940 Olympics?
Uh,
anyways,
yes.
That's what this fucking guy does,
right?
He gives me my
long story short,
I get my eggs,
my eggs are fucking cold and now my post is as hot as hell.
And uh,
you know,
that's an element,
you know what I mean?
Goddamn home and the pilot fucking days going to go.
You know,
when you can't get your breakfast to coincide on a temperature,
it's just really annoying.
Um,
but you know,
Jesus Christ,
what is he even saying?
Amazing
to people with really foreign sounding names.
She said that last name too is if there's another guy named Barack Obama and the
fucking airport,
um,
oof.
Jesus.
I'm going to move it.
Oh God.
It's not a special announcement when you have an announcement every three
seconds.
Oh,
should I keep my bag with me?
I was going to leave it down the fucking street.
You cannot take a pistol onto the plane.
Even if you're in first class.
What?
I can't stand these fucking announcements like some God damn child can be five
seconds telling me what I can and can't do.
Just tell me what I can't do it.
That's what I don't like.
That little hot Stuart are sitting over there playing Sodoku.
I'm trying to attract a man.
Show the cheese,
the classy flight attendant.
She's not a Sky Horn and she's in the puzzle copy mean she doesn't drink.
But you'd be surprised.
I bet she gives a good blow job.
Oh look at me.
Give you a little sex joke.
I just stay away from that material
cause it's so easy to get a laugh.
I get chuckling in your cubicle right now people.
Um,
all right.
Your collective cubicle.
Anyways,
that's my fucking three cheese on with,
with the,
uh,
delayed white toast story slash Tourette's over the fucking announcements.
Um,
if you do it on my page,
this is the Monday morning podcast hosted by me.
Next week I'll have a guest house,
I'll be sick and uh,
some feature I call up his myself and he'll complain about the bay.
Oh,
he bought.
Um,
so anyways,
I do one of these every week.
I uh,
answer questions and I uh,
you know,
people send me questions and Oh,
speaking of that,
um,
I want to apologize to the person that I trashed last week for asking me where
exactly they send the questions to.
Evidently somebody hacked my account and got rid of the place where it says add
friends,
send a message.
So I imagine that would be confusing even though he did still send me an email,
but I want to thank uh,
the two or three people gave me the heads up.
Um,
I'm trying to think who the fuck would hack my account so I couldn't add
friends.
Um,
shortlist would probably be other comedians.
Uh Oh hang on a second.
Hang down while I thought that now they,
they're telling the agent people what they can and can't do when they get on
the,
on the flight.
Uh,
no shop in chopstick allowed in the common area.
Um,
you know,
there was not only racist,
it was also hacky chopsticks bill.
You couldn't come up with a more original fucking artifact from the Orient.
You know what,
I can't,
I'm actually at a loss.
We had chopsticks these,
these,
these are the hacky references I have from the Far East chopsticks,
Sushi,
which are kind of the same thing.
They go hand in hand,
a Kabuki.
Um,
and then that one guy who stood in front of that tank at Tiananmen Square,
um,
oh,
Buddhist monks protesting whatever the fuck it is giant is doing to them.
You know what China is doing to,
uh,
to back.
They're doing the same thing with these fucking people in the year we afforded
doing over the announcements.
That's what it's like living at the bet.
Constant announcements over your head.
They no plane,
no Tibet monk,
no Gregorian chant from 1230 to one 30.
All right.
Was that a sense of enough?
I hope so.
Okay.
Uh,
anyway,
so people send me,
uh,
whatever.
They send me questions and I answered them to the best of my ability.
People send me conspiracy theory.
Uh,
somebody sent me a great link,
but I'm sitting here in the airport and I can't open that shit without having to
pay for fucking Internet,
which is I refuse to do,
cause I'm already doing it.
I'm already doing it on my Goddamn fucking place out in California,
but whoever it was at,
send me that thing.
I really wish I could stay in and do that.
That that conspiracy theory thing was hilarious and all this stuff about nine 11
Hitler.
And,
uh,
what I loved about it was the usual,
the usual categories of conspiracy theory.
But somehow everything came back to blaming Jewish people,
literally to the point that this website was actually trying to suggest that you
wish people were actually financially backing Hitler and his whole movement.
I mean,
I dunno.
It was just fucking,
it was hilarious.
There's about shit,
another announcement.
How do people get locked in the airport?
You know what I mean?
How do you get separated?
Like,
this place is on fire and everybody's fucking running.
Everybody has cell phones.
I don't understand the need to still paid somebody tangent into [inaudible] and
Philip Rivers and who the fuck is,
oh,
he's the quarterback for fucking San Diego.
I forget.
I can't even come up with a fake name.
I said Philips second.
That was a good fake name.
And then I panicked.
I don't want to rivers rivers see a hotheaded quarterback.
Oh,
no,
no.
That's not the hot headed quarterback.
That's his.
Uh,
that's the braggadocious one.
Who was the original?
Who's that fucking quarterback for?
The charges were screaming at that reporter.
Fuck was his name.
Number one draft.
Ryan Leaf.
We taste so many.
You brought up there who listened to this podcast and you're not into,
uh,
sports.
You still should go on Google,
Google,
Ryan Leaf,
r y a n l e a f.
Oh wait,
Google it.
And uh,
you know,
if you thought your husband was an asshole and I had a chance,
and sort of would berate you.
You got to see when he yells at this report,
it's awesome.
No one gave off the date rape but better than Ryan Leaf.
Um,
one of the great characters,
one of the great busts in NFL history.
Anybody else moves?
Tony Mander rich set his fucking name.
Who's The guy being credible?
Woke up at 400 pound guy on roids.
The packers picked up,
he showed up with his muscles and his acne and uh,
I dunno what happened next and ran,
they gave him an uppercut and just ended his career.
I don't really never really did shit.
Oh wait.
Oh,
okay.
Todd Marinovich.
That's the other guy.
That's the guy thought I confused it with the guy from USC who's dad was making
a run for forties.
As a toddler.
I was at least timing them in the 40.
Um,
I dunno what the fuck I'm talking about this point.
I'm gonna have to sleep.
Um,
so anyways,
let's get on with the podcast questions.
Oh,
but before I do,
I'm fans of my radio show that I do with that Joe to Rosa,
um,
who's in my top,
uh,
46 on my space.
If you look,
he's the second one over.
Uh,
we do a radio show on Xm two o two once a month.
It comes out on a Saturday.
The next one we have is going to be on Saturday,
may the 24th.
We just prerecorded it.
Uh,
we had a great show.
Me and Joe both have incredible tempers and we scream at each other and that's
the show.
And uh,
actually the show is a guest.
We had an anger management therapist come on to analyze our anger and try to
figure out why were a couple of psychos.
And uh,
I got to met Nan.
She got right around by defenses.
She got in real close.
She was like right in my grill emotionally.
And uh,
it was fucking uncomfortable,
but I think it may for some good radio.
Um,
so please check that out.
And uh,
what else?
I'm going to be at a xannies in Chicago on May 14th through that Sunday.
I think I don't have my calendar in front of me.
This is gonna be real sketchy.
Um,
but the date should be right there.
You can click on it and uh,
find out where I'm going to be case you don't understand how fucking computers
work.
All right.
What else?
I got out Caroline Caroline's comedy club in,
uh,
New York City.
I'm gonna be there from May 29th to June 1st and Joe Rosa we'll be featuring and
uh,
in June I'm going to be in a,
the fucking,
my good night's comedy clubs,
Raleigh,
North Carolina,
and I'll be at the punchline in Atlanta,
Georgia,
Atlanta as the brothers calling.
Um,
when the hell am I going to be there?
Something like fucking June 19th or something.
I Dunno,
I don't have the stuff in front of me.
Okay.
All right.
I'm in a bad mood or rite aid.
Cold eggs and fucking hot toast.
It's enough to make anybody in fucking irritable.
Um,
God,
I can't wait to get old and dress like dad.
Look at this fucking mess set on a pink Hoodie with lime green slacks,
Capri slacks that cover all the varicose veins down who calves and no socks and
then some sort of Michael Jackson loafers,
southern guy.
He looks like
the guy would say he murdered his wife.
You know,
he's probably got a bottle of peroxide even though,
so I'm able to be murders.
Said why if there was go with the peroxide then I talked about that last week.
You know what I mean?
Like that's going to help you fucking London lady over here with a pants suit.
You know,
I should talk right now I have on tracks sneakers,
track snickers.
Is that actually a fucking brand of sneakers?
I don't know what it is.
They're Russ silver with a red Nike swoosh.
It was probably sewn on by a fucking three year old in Bangladesh.
And,
uh,
I have on jeans and a suede leather coat.
Um,
yeah,
I guess I'm looking like an asshole to her,
but they have another person sitting here some up and coming comedian doing a
podcast and then actually making fun of me.
I want to do that fucking area and look inside.
Go over there.
Why would you wear a fucking suede jacket with some tracks?
Sneakers,
unless you stole the jacket and you had to get the fuck out of there quickly,
but enough about theories.
All right,
let's get it home with the,
uh,
the podcast questions of the week.
Um,
okay.
Bill,
you said you love shit that is not meant to be funny,
but you find it to be that way.
Uh,
we try to read that sentence in a pace that will actually make sense and it
really awkward pauses in it.
You know what I mean?
Like if you,
if you take the most basic sentence and you pause in a weird area,
people don't even know what the fuck you're talking about.
And I think I just started to read it at an even tempo one t won't.
All right,
Bill,
you said,
you said you love shit that is not meant to be funny,
but you find it to be that way.
Say now it makes sense.
It made sense to me.
I got lost the first time I ran it.
Just why not read?
Cause I just get confused and it just really holds a mirror up to my stupidity
and if I'm alone,
it's a very scary moment.
Um,
okay.
So what is your favorite movie that you find funny that is not meant to be
funny?
Um,
there's so much shit I can't even start.
You know what?
This is really the little stewardess haven over here.
Now there's three stewardesses sitting there.
This looks like the beginning of a porno.
You know,
like all I need to do is just walk into frame and next thing you know what's
going to be on baby.
Um,
okay.
What is my favorite movie that I find funny that's not meant to be funny.
Um,
there's too many of them.
You know,
roadhouse.
He never seen row house.
Some of you youngsters out there,
you got to see stars.
Patrick Swayze,
I believe.
That's why I have his picture there.
Um,
roadhouse is basically about a boss.
Fuck my cell phone's going to die,
get damaged.
Let me get quickly here.
Roadhouses about a rough and tumble bar and they can't seem to get a control
over it.
So they hire this bouncer from,
I don't know where,
but he basically has a reputation on the bouncer circuit.
That's what I love about it.
Like there's this bounce their circuit like Comedians,
you know what I mean?
Like people are out there like going,
Oh did you hear Chris Rock's new hour and 45 like there's like the Chris rock of
bouncers out there,
you know like who's your favorite bouncer?
Like up and coming bouncers have a favorite fucking bouncer.
It's money where they bring in,
they bring in Patrick Swayze,
all 138 pounds of him with his feathered mullet to come in and clean this
fucking bar up.
And two of my favorite scenes in there is when after he gets hired,
he gets into his Mercedes Benz and they're playing this music and then,
and then,
and the show him,
I can put it on the ray ban glasses,
it's horse shit.
And at one point he slide the cassette tape.
It like that with some fucking amazing,
I guess it was an amazing option at that point.
And uh,
there's that moment and the moment when he leans against the bar and this really
bad white blues music is playing and he's doing this weird sort of fucking head
nod to the music that's supposed to imply that he's tough.
Um,
I dunno,
my cell phone's going to die,
can't explain it,
but a Roadhouse,
any movie that has Clint Howard in it.
And uh,
I signed Fox News to be fucking absolutely hilarious.
Just the fact that people actually look at it like it's an actual news and these
people are journalists and uh,
and you know,
Bill O'reilly's always fucking hilarious screaming at people if the,
and then just making over the top comments.
Like the Second Amendment is the most important amendment out there,
the right to bear arms.
If anything taught us that it was hurricane Katrina.
He actually fucking said that.
And then a nice drum and then started talking about who against the kind of
cover his tracks.
But he got the message out there.
All right,
let me answer this next question really quickly before my cell phone down.
Uh,
I was wondering if you're into comic books or how you fucking whore.
Nobody cares.
Your announcement.
Jeez.
And Shit on the concourse.
Why don't you repeat it a third time?
All right.
Uh,
I was wondering if you were in comic books and if you were at all,
uh,
blah,
blah.
Who are your favorite ones?
I was in the Spiderman and um,
there was actually one of my favorite comic,
which is a kid who was a comic book with Spiderman and this guy powerment uh,
this black guy,
this black superhero.
And he had this yellow shirt,
you know,
they always dress very flamboyantly and somehow there was a fire in a building
and he saved the fire,
the firemen.
So it was just a really cool one.
And quite like the movies they make about a comics and it's,
no,
I don't because most of them ended up being a chick flicks.
You know what?
You should ask that question to Keith Robinson cause he's the one who really
fucking called,
uh,
it's not special.
Not a special announcement.
Every five fucking seconds.
Uh,
no one's going to abandon their luggage.
Okay.
All right.
It's time to wrap this fucking podcast up.
All right,
I'm going to go over there and go hit on these stewardesses and see if I can
make that fantasy come true.
Can even hear me.
Anyways,
I want to thank everybody for listening to the Monday morning podcasts and
setting in,
uh,
the questions.
Please keep sending me the conspiracy theory and all that tech stuff and I just
want to thank everybody who came out to helium comedy club out in Philadelphia.
I had a,
had a great time down there and uh,
no boy nothing.
It was actually a great crowds are actually really,
uh,
crowds too.
Who Knew,
right?
They had a great time.
So thanks to everybody who came out and,
uh,
sorry,
this podcast is so short,
short and sweet,
but I'm going to run out of batteries here,
so I'll talk to all you guys next week.
Uh,
the link is backup,
so please keep sending me the questions.
All right,
everybody.
Have a good week.
Thanks.
Bye.
Special reports
in the United States.
Interesting.
In many people.
Okay.